[Rires]
de Montréal détruites dans les Cantons
de l'Est de l'ombre chevalier dans un
quartier industriel si ça se fait au
Québec ça s'élève aussi
on est au tour de 1100 tonnes de
production le total de poissons en
pisciculture trs au Québec
pour 100 de la pisciculture sur terre et
destinée au marché de la table le reste
sert ensemencer nous lacs
majoritairement ça va venir soit de
l'Est du Canada ça va dire les provinces
maritimes Nouveau-Brunswick sinon une
grosse partie de ce qu'on va retrouver
ça va venir du Chili qui est un très
gros producteur mondial qui a une
problématique parce que la co-culture
est en train d'exploser partout sur la
planète
sauf ici alors qu'on était assis sur un
potentiel d'eau et de terrain et
d'électricité qui théoriquement nous
permettrait d'avoir des grosses
productions ou à tout le moins plusieurs
petites qui combleraient le marché
intérieur
pisciculteur dans Charlevoix Benoît
Michel big 26 poissons dans la région de
Québec le gros marché c'est vraiment la
restauration c'est vraiment là que la
demande les marchés d'épicerie sont plus
durs à percer étant donné que les
volumes sont faibles
c'est la protéine probablement qui va
être la plus importante pour les 100
prochaines années
le masque dans son plan stratégique
avait déterminé de doubler 17 2025 la
production du Québec quand on y va sur
ce qui est autorisé avec le projet
qui vient d'être autorisant Gaspésie
mais le MAPA qui aurait atteint son
objectif de doubler la production ce
serait le premier producteur de saumon
au Québec mais est-ce qu'il reste encore
du développement malgré ce projet là oui
des plus grands joueurs en Gaspésie et
en Estrie et des plus petits qui font
leur place et ça a changé ici depuis que
depuis la dernière fois qu'on est venu
d'élevage on a 11 bassins et c'est ça on
pense produire de 25 à 30 tonnes donc
chevalier annuellement
au pire que les devenu la première
pisciculture en milieu urbain à opérer
au Québec en plein quartier industriel à
Montréal donc ça va être principalement
pour
des restaurants ou des petites
épiceries potentiellement plus gros
épicerie pour le candide
des restos qu'on veut des serveurs
puis cette livraison de se faire
véhicule électrique d'ailleurs vélo
électrique ou voiture électrique juste
ici
mais pour le moment le ruselu qui peut
faire goûter les poissons David est un
des premiers restaurateurs au Québec à
offrir que du local sur sa carte vous
êtes le premier restaurateur à avoir pu
pêcher directement à Montréal
on attendait plus que lui soit prête
puis c'est juste cool comme projet puis
c'est cool qu'on est qu'on est capable
de faire partir John c'est un passionné
ici qui veut tester des nouvelles choses
il aime travailler des produits
différents puis qui sont qui marchent
avec sa vision dans le fond on fait un
poisson très écologique ça c'est un
parti pour éviter le gaspillage de la
neige de la guerre c'est le prix enfin
c'est sûr qu'il faut arriver avec un
produit qui va être un prix qu'on va
dire raisonnable je pense qu'on est
capable de le faire dans une certaine
mesure
c'est pas une si grosse différence que
ça en termes de prix
versus les autres produits qu'on va
avoir en épicerie qui vont venir de
l'extérieur là c'est finalement on paye
une taxe environnementale un peu les
autres ici on s'est doté des normes
environnementales qui sont pratiquement
les plus sévères de la planète 1000 fois
plus sévère que celle du Chili c'est ça
c'est sûr et certain aux autres le gros
de l'élevage se fait en cage marine dans
l'océan
des normes que conteste parfois les
aquaculteurs est-ce que c'est pire pour
l'environnement de produire ici en pas
loin un petit peu ou d'acheter un
produit qui vient de l'extérieur qui a
fait des milliers de kilomètres tu sais
c'est des fois ça c'est des choix de
société qu'il faut garder quelqu'un qui
veut s'établir une nouvelle entreprise
psychicole il y a des normes
environnementales relativement stricts
qui exige d'être en mesure de rejeter le
phosphore produit par les poissons dans
un milieu récepteur qui est hâte à
recevoir ce phosphore nous ici on était
dans des bassins extérieurs
à la pisciculture des bobines on a
décidé d'investir et d'innover pour
prendre d'assaut le marché on a décidé
de pour être capable de mieux contrôler
nos rejets de faire une bonne six puis
avec des systèmes de filtration fait que
la production ici présentement est de
210 tonnes on travaille en circulation
intensé on utilise seulement que 8 %
d'eau fraîches on chauffe l'eau la
plupart des éleveurs en mer se font dans
des caves flottants faites-le à ce
moment-là c'est certain que le problème
c'est la difficulté de contrôler les
maladies mais souvent sont obligés de
tuer des antibiotiques tandis que un
milieu terrestre on contrôle toutes les
paramètres
la pisciculture les bobines est la seule
pour le moment à distribuer ces produits
en épicerie en Estrie et à Montréal
on est en voie d'augmentation de
production mais on pourrait jamais subir
à la demande québécoise en tant que
producteur personnel comme des bobines
il faudrait qu'il y ait d'autres
producteurs qui s'intéressent à la
production
justement depuis 2016 aquaponie et eau
développent et accompagne des nouveaux
projets en pisciculture au Québec on
développe des fermes aquaponiques un peu
partout au Québec donc c'est des fermes
qui produisent des poissons mais
également des produits maraîchers donc
des fruits des légumes tout au long de
l'année puis c'est implantable en milieu
urbain donc près du lieu de consommation
c'est la combinaison de deux
technologies l'aquaculture l'élevage
d'organismes aquatique des poissons
crustacés mais aussi l'hydroponie donc
tout ce qui est culture hors sol
il y a des gens qui ne connaissent pas
nécessairement ce poisson là si vous
aviez un décrire
ça goûte
dans la famille de truite saumon alors
les goûts se ressemblent
normalement ça dépend beaucoup de la
maturité de l'ongle à quel point ça
goûte ou non à les jeunes c'est vraiment
c'est doux c'est comme
avec vos poissons
c'est vraiment délicieux donc on y croit
comme consommateur qu'on va pouvoir
manger de la truite de l'ongle très
prochainement dans nos assiettes c'est
on pense qu'une décennie c'est proche
[Musique]
des discuteurs qui ont produisent déjà
en profite déjà et on travaille très
fort oui avec les promoteurs pour en
ajouter dans les prochaines années
[Musique]